so this one came in from adam from santa
monica
oh wait that's me
i am i i was going to say this so we
should have actually called in and left
a voicemail and then we could play it i
should have
um adam from santa monica is beyond
outrage
this we talked about this we were pivot
wanted to pivot away from talking about
anything political
that last bit aside um because
i'm just like the the sort of content
moderation is is
highly political it is but we're not
really talking about like party politics
and that kind of stuff we're talking
about
issues that that concern us all um but
i'm kind of so beyond outraged i
couldn't watch the impeachment i didn't
want anything i didn't have any more
energy for it
and i was just thinking like how do we
move beyond outrage as a people
because i've always found anger to be
very powerful it's a powerful tool
um it can drive you in
in productive ways but if it stagnates
it can become bitterness which i think
we saw on your feed
some of that and bitterness is so
counterproductive i think it fuels
almost
everything bad that we see that kind of
bubbles the surface here
lately um so i guess the question is you
know
how do you move beyond outrage and anger
yeah i mean isn't that the 64 question
i mean yeah you're mine as well my
outrage
stores have been depleted i feel
incapable of it at the moment
but you know i have to also recognize
that
that depletion of my outrage is perhaps
you know on some level a function of of
privilege
you know because i'm not in need at the
moment and i think we have to
deconstruct this question from two
perspectives
from the kind of greater social
uh community
aspects of outrage and what's fueling
that and what the antidote is and then
our own individual behavior that we can
take responsibility for because i think
broadly culturally nationally we're not
going to be able to move beyond outrage
until we solve some very large problems
that we face
most particularly um the
the wage gap you know we're in we're in
a situation where the middle class has
disappeared
the division between the haves and the
have-nots have never been greater in the
midst of the pandemic the richest people
have enriched themselves beyond
measure when they could have used that
wealth to
you know basically uh confront
the coronavirus pandemic for the benefit
of the less well-off like there's plenty
of things that
the most landed gentry class in our
country
could have been of service to us in a
way that that that we didn't see
right meanwhile people are losing their
jobs they're losing their health
insurance we're not seeing any any
real effort regarding like how to
resolve any of this
and that that wealth gap is only going
to exacerbate and i think
um you know over the course of history
if you study history when that gap
becomes too
large the foundations upon which that
culture
are are embedded begin to fracture
and either revolution or some other
force
intervenes and that's how changes in
government
occur when we have so many people who
are suffering at the moment
we can't begrudge them for their outrage
now
that outrage gets stoked by
the news cycle and social media
apps that that you know provoke that
outrage
and and you know exacerbate it to some
extent and i think we all need to be
aware of the extent to which our anger
gets
triggered but i'm sympathetic to people
who are outraged right now because
their lives are not what they should be
or what they could be
in this moment on an individual basis
when i look at my own um
how i comport myself and how i behave
and how i deal with people who
are outraged or i'm in a context in
which somebody's angry at me
i have to think about the conversation
that i had with adam grant
you know and and and how he talks about
and how the science
um what the science reveals about
how to have more productive
conversations and how to ameliorate
tensions and
and it's not like i haven't talked about
this before it all goes back to
leading with empathy you know entering
these conversations
with humility and with curiosity as
opposed to
a need or a desire to change somebody
else's mind
if you ask somebody that's interesting
that that's how you feel or that's the
way you see things tell me more about
that or
walk me through the process of how you
arrived at that conclusion i think
that's always the way in
but when you come at it aggressively
then you're in a position where you're
butting heads
nobody's mind is getting changed and
you're just basically
um doubling down on the difference
and the acrimony that lives and breathes
between
two different people yeah um further to
that
what is the solution if you if you enter
those conversations with that
spirit of empathy humility and curiosity
well you have to be willing to sit down
for a while
right and that's where i think long-form
conversations come in that's why i
believe in podcasting so much
as an antidote to all of this you know
podcasting
because of the open nature source of it
the fact that it's an rss feed and and
that it's not about
click bait titles and um
and you know trying to uh you know game
the system not that the system doesn't
get gamed in other ways
but there's something unique about it um
there is no
like podcasting suffers from a
discoverability problem like
unlike youtube or other things like you
it's it's difficult to find new stuff
and it's difficult to kind of game you
can't do it with a clickbait
title right right so i believe that the
best stuff
eventually rises to the top and my hope
and my belief is that
um you know these types of long-form
conversations are what people
need right now and we crave it nobody
wants to live in a place of
fear anger and acrimony as familiar as
it might feel right now
and i think that's a reason why people
are cottoning on to
these long-form podcasts because there
is
it is a salve to that in some regard
yeah
and i think you know there's also
uh individually we have to kind of
salve our own wounds as well at the same
time because outrage you can't run on
outrage no matter what you're not a
sustainable fuel source it's just not
no matter where you are in the world and
and you know
you know how how rightfully outraged you
may be
um you gotta you gotta figure out a way
to
feel yourself some other way you know to
some
from some other inspiration
um because really the only solutions
like you said are some
structural changes some some changes for
us to like figure
out a way to live to be to live better
together it's unity really is the only
right
and recognizing that not everybody you
know is on the same starting line
that so many of us myself included you
know had tremendous advantages and we
have to we have to reckon with that and
we've gotta
you know create um social systems that
provide greater opportunity for people
that you know aren't
didn't you know weren't blessed with
what i was blessed with you know growing
up
and we need to address that we need to
address the
you know the the the wealth inequality
that's
there's so many problems right so i
guess what i'm saying is
is you know how do we it's not a simple
matter
of like just comport yourself better
like we have systemic problems that we
have to solve and
and so to be outraged at the outrage is
not the solution
either no but you know the the i guess
the biggest problem with the outrage
uh level that we have to me is it's not
that's outrage is not a path towards
solving those problems right
ultimately you know it's understandable
it's an understandable reaction but
ultimately
it's not a path to solution it might be
a path to
garnering some sort of political power
that can put you in onto the path of
actually making the change though
so you know
we're done with outrage for a little
while you think well i don't know
you just you speak too soon my friend
i would not i'm fueled by rage okay it's
okay
but i'm i'm just tired of this the
familiar the familiar tune
so
[Music]
you